Grammy Award winner and philanthropist
Jon Bon Jovi is honoring our veterans
and their service with his new song
unbroken
for the next 12 months all proceeds from
the song will go to the patriotic
service dog foundation the nonprofit
provides highly trained service dogs to
veterans in need at no costs
Bon Jovi wrote the anthem for the new
documentary to be of service about
veterans who live with PTSD and the
service animals who help them heal
getting my dog getting my Timothy it was
second only to my child so I took
medication and I didn't want to be a
zombie
we've looked up I look to him and he ran
to me that's when everything started to
get a lot better very powerful
documentary and John Bongiovi is with us
good morning thanks for coming in thank
you yes talk to us about this song which
you've written from the perspective of a
service member how did you go about
writing it I was asked to write the song
and it was going to be a difficult task
because I hadn't served in the military
you all if you were the right guy to
write it sure because the goal is honest
you have to be honest if you're gonna
take on this task and yet be truthful in
its delivery so that men and women who
did serve will feel a pride when they
hear this song so I talked to the
director prior to his having to cut put
together he gave me some key anecdotal
lines that the soldiers had discussed
with him and I asked him what is the
name the title of the film was he said
to be of service and I said yeah I mean
and when I watched the documentary and I
heard the song it's like you captured
everything so brilliantly in your song
because they talked about what the dogs
mean to them serving 20 to 22 people a
day die from suicide who were veterans
but the thing that got me in the dock
all of them said they would do it all
again and that's what you said in your
song too I was trying to find hope at
the end of the journey here and to think
that each of these men and women said
the one thing is that I would do it all
again when you're making a record you
usually end it with the chorus yeah in
this case it was such a powerful line
that while we were recording it we said
no this is the end of the song the
journey ends
with the positivity so the proceeds for
this for the song will go to a service
dog foundation I think that's a
beautiful thing my odd actually trained
service dog Oh fantastic and she tells
me some of the stories and I was
interested in the documentary to learn
that the Department of Veterans Affairs
supports veterans with PTSD but does not
actually support funding of service dogs
for those veterans with PTSD do you
think the government is doing enough
well I think that they're doing their
surveys to make sure that the training
is done properly and my education
obviously is on the first page of the
book but what I've been led to believe
is that the process is again going
through Congress to try to get a bill
passed so the government will support
this see that documentary John is you
know what yeah they said the dogs are
better than medication than therapy than
a prosthetic I looked at that and I
found it overwhelming with the
difference of the dogs what did this doc
mean to you personally you said you
haven't served but your family certainly
well if your parents or Marines my mom
and dad had in the Marine Corps which i
think is pretty neat yeah and she wasn't
afraid of boot camp yeah well it was
service was always important if my
parents told us that and although I
didn't serve my three best buddies there
were four of us in high school we all
got the call I had a belief that I was
gonna be you know doing what I do the
other three guys join the Navy you know
so that's where we come from you have a
foundation with this really struck me
you have a foundation that helped fund
something called the new Walter Reed
veteran's apartments tell us what that
is
77 units thus far of affordable housing
for vets with services all under one
roof we partnered would help us a it's
not the first time I've partnered with
the great organization help us a to
build houses for veterans yeah and and
it's not only housing for them there's
support for them and service providing
is the key element yeah yeah so they can
get any kind of medical legal advice
there's as well up job opportunities all
under these roof I think philanthropy is
your middle name John Bongiovi I
remember Hurricane Katrina when Oprah
was raising money for the victims down
there he came with a million dollar
check we all know about your your your
soul2soul kitchens that you have in New
Jersey
that you and Dorothy are are helping to
feed people there I mean there's
something you have that gene that you
want to give back and you want to help
people well it I don't need the
scientists to find the cure in these
cases you really don't a little bit of
money a lot of sweat you know and you
know that's what we do with this whole
kitchens your new album Bon Jovi 2020
you said is a socially conscious record
not a political one what's the
difference between take sides in this
issue for example yeah no I'm just
speaking as the soldier the the album is
called 2020 there's it's an election
year there's a rymus in the title you
think about getting in they said the
President Clinton and I whose job was
better I said mine he said well why do
you say that so because I got to keep
the house in the airplane this album
which has passed songs on it almost did
not have living on a prayer including
the true and what did not well when we
wrote slippery all those years ago I
thought it's okay maybe we should give
this one away and and Ritchie slapped me
upside the head because it was so
different if you think about that song
it didn't sound like anything on any
radio station at a time it was unique we
created a different vibe would you
didn't think it fit on the album I just
thought it was oh it was so different it
was weird you know but what's the
difference between so she conscious and
political because you said you take note
I take no sides there's songs on this
forthcoming record that that address
guns there's the the atmosphere in
Washington there's the soldiers with
PTSD that's a very different record then
you give up a bad name yeah take what I
don't take sides
yeah it's because look we are entitled
to our opinions right and so that's what
America is we're supposed to govern all
Americans together and represent all
together and I think this record does
that but it is obvious and what I'm
speaking right John Bongiovi thank you
for coming into college
thank you really appreciate it and again
all the proceeds from downloads of
unbroken with this prayer I'm hoping we
can be unbroken currently go to the
patriotic service dog foundation
to be of service is available right now
on Netflix